but we begin here this morning with a
still uncertain outcome of the midterm
elections Democrats are inching closer
to maintaining their slim Senate
majority overnight CBS News projected
incumbent Arizona Democrat Mark Kelly to
win his race over Republican Challenger
Blake Masters meanwhile the outcome of
two other contests that will determine
which party controls the Senate remains
undecided Nevada's Senate race between
Democrat Catherine Cortez masto and
Republican Adam black salt remains a
toss-up this morning with votes still
being tallied and Georgia's contest
between Rafael Warnock and Herschel
Walker is headed to a runoff next month
with those two races still outstanding
the Senate is currently at 49 Democrats
and 49 Republicans if Democrats win one
more seat though they'll hold the
majority with a tie-breaking vote of
Vice President Kamala Harris
control of the House of Representatives
has yet to be decided CBS News does rate
the house as leaning Republican
meanwhile Arizona's hotly contested
governor's race between Democratic
Secretary of State Katie Hobbs and
former television news anchor Curry Lake
remains a toss-up this morning
a lot to get to Christina raffini is in
Phoenix where votes in Arizona's races
are still being counted Christina good
morning to you
good morning Jeff from a surprisingly
chilly Phoenix Arizona those numbers
released last night were critical not
only because they helped push Mark Mark
Kelly over the edge of his Republican
challenger but also because they
included the first bash of those day of
drop-off ballots now the theory had been
that those ballads would be heavily
Republican because those would be the
people that didn't trust the the mail-in
ballot system enough to put them in the
mail and they wanted to take them into
the polling place themselves the day of
so far however that hasn't happened now
we're only seeing the first batch but
Democrats are still in the lead
Christina how has this impacted the
governor's race and and what are you
hearing from the candidates
the governor's race has not been called
yet and that's because it's simply too
close and it's within the margin of era
of those outstanding ballots there's
still about 300 000 ballots that they're
going to be counting over the weekend in
this building behind me they're working
through the holiday weekend and you know
one of the things that we've seen is
that the governor's race is
um Democrat Katie Hobbs increased her
leads slightly yesterday over Republican
Kerry Lake it is still a toss-up they're
going to count another 80 000 or so
votes tonight most of those are going to
be from those election day ballots so
they could potentially swing the race a
little bit in Lake's favor but that's
looking less and less likely as the
Democrat maintains her lead in that race
well Christina why is it taking this
much time to count all of Arizona's
votes and what are Republicans saying
about this delay
yeah it's taking that much time because
what they are confusingly calling the
late early ballots those people who
walked in their mail-in ballots to the
voting place the day up because unlike
going up to a machine pressing a button
and having that vote be tabulated when
you bring your mail-in ballot it then
has to be unfolded it has to be verified
and a bipartisan team has to check the
signature that takes time of course the
longer it takes the more time there's
been for Republicans including former
president Trump to cast doubts on the
process Republican gubernatorial
candidate Carrie lake has called
officials here in Maricopa County quote
incompetent and the RNC and Arizona
Republican party issued a statement
yesterday saying the election has
exposed deep flaws in the system here
Arizona deserves better and they're
pushing for a more prompt announcement
of election results however the
individual in charge of the process here
in Maricopa County a republican said
look they don't make the laws but
they're going to follow them it's an
arduous process it takes time if you
don't like it don't complain to them
take it up with your State Legislature
all right to be continued Christina
thank you